welcome back to cbs saturday morning we
begin this half hour celebrating queen
elizabeth ii on the eve of her 70th
anniversary on the british throne it was
on february 6 1952 when a then 25 year
old elizabeth was first crowned
following the death of her father
presidents popes and prime ministers
have since come and gone the soviet
union has collapsed but the queen's
reign goes on roxanna saberi has more on
her platinum jubilee
[Music]
queen elizabeth didn't plan on putting
on the crown so soon
her father king george vi had been
gravely ill when he waved her and her
husband philip off on the royal tour the
year before
the grievous news of her father's death
reached the young queen now age 25
she and her husband returned immediately
to london
her coronation became the first major
international event broadcast live on tv
a burst of pageantry in post-war britain
that thrusts the young queen onto a
throne of privilege
stardom and responsibility i declare
before you all
that my whole life
whether it be long or short
shall be devoted to your service over
the past seven decades queen elizabeth
has overseen the transition from
britain's imperial past to a more modern
monarchy and navigated the clash of
public scrutiny with her family's
private life from princess diana's death
and the departure of prince harry and
his wife megan to allegations of sexual
assault now facing prince andrew
she's also guided her country through
the pandemic
and i want to reassure you that if we
remain united and resolute
then we will overcome it royal
correspondent roy anika constant polling
in this country shows that she is still
enormously popular and that people are
still very proud of the monarchy and i
think that really is
an outpouring of of
gratitude for her
the uk is preparing to celebrate her
platinum jubilee with stamps souvenirs
and four days of festivities in june but
on sunday the 95 year old queen is
expected to mark her seven decades on
the throne as she does every year in
quiet reflection for cbs saturday
morning roxanna suberi london
what she has lived through and served
through amazing yeah yeah she might
outlive us all and only 25 when she i
know right so 840 days she is away from
passing louis xiv knew as long as
reigning our executive officer brian
applegate did yes but the french king
dolphin king from france yeah okay but
big lou was only four when he took over
the throne wow and reigned for 72 years
which makes me wonder how he was ruling
but that's a whole other i don't know
different times he actually wasn't big
was he was small when he took over
anyway